un acto recíproco pondría punto final a
una amarga disputa diplomática entre
eeuu y china que ha durado más de 1000
días
después de más de 1000 días de
sufrimiento finalmente regresé a mi
patria la larga espera en el extranjero
estuvo llena de luchas y sufrimientos
pero cuando bajé las escaleras y
aterricé me emociono la calidez de mi
ciudad natal está más allá de las
palabras sin patria estoy de regreso
después de llegar a un acuerdo con
fiscales estadounidenses la ejecutiva e
hija del fundador de la multinacional
china huawei aterrizó en casa desde
vancouver canadá tras haber pasado tres
años en prisión
el hecho de que menguan joe pueda ser
declarada no culpable y liberada es una
gran victoria en política y diplomacia
para la gente de china
siempre he creído que menguan joe podría
volver a casa tarde o temprano
yo también lo creo y esto se debe a que
china se ha convertido en un país
poderoso ella finalmente está en casa ha
sido muy difícil para ella
en aparente respuesta dos canadienses
que permanecían en custodia de las
autoridades chinas también fueron
liberados y recibidos en calgary por el
primer ministro justin trudeau bng el
guangzhou fue arrestada en diciembre de
2018 por orden de un tribunal de nueva
york acusada de tratar de encubrir los
intentos de empresas vinculadas a huawei
de vender equipos a irán violando las
sanciones de la casa blanca mientras que
el empresario michaels facebook y el ex
diplomático michael cover fueron
detenidos días después bajo cargos de
espionaje una supuesta diplomacia de
rehenes en la que china siempre negó
haber participado